(audience cheers)
- Welcome back. We are here
with Catherine Zeta Jones!
Give it up, y'all!
(audience cheers)
Catherine's new Disney Plus series
is called "National
Treasure, Edge of History".
The show involves
searching for old relics,
often in very quiet places like museums,
churches, and libraries.
So we thought we'd see how
well Catherine and I do
at identifying quiet sounds with the game
I am 100% sure I've
never won on this show.
(audience laugh)
This is another round of "A Quiet Case".
(light music)
♪ A quiet case ♪
(audience applauds)
- Go ahead, Jesse.
All right, here to host and
make sure there's no cheating.
Please welcome, good friend of the show
and host of American Ninja Warrior on NBC,
Matt Eisenman, everybody.
(all cheer)
(upbeat music)
- Thank you, Catherine.
- It's great to see you again.
- It's so nice being here.
- I haven't seen you in a while.
- I'm so glad you're back. I know.
- Thank you for hosting, though.
What are, tell us the rules.
- Okay, so this game is "A Quiet Case",
and you can see there are
eight cases on the stage
with eight everyday items in them.
- Okay.
- Now Catherine, you and Kelly
will take turns selecting a case.
When a case is selected,
I will bring it up here
to the center, and I will use the item.
The first one of you to buzz in
and correctly name the
item will get the point.
But, if you're wrong, steals are allowed.
- Okay.
- Which.
- And Catherine.
- Be ready to steal,
'cause I'm always wrong.
- She's so bad at this. (Kelly laughs)
The last time we played, the
chicks beat her so badly,
She had to-
- So sad.
- I think, I think it's a foil.
I think she's really good
and she's just saying that to get ahead.
- I'm not a shark. I'm
telling you, it's not a.
- Okay.
- Nope, nope, it's real bad.
- She's quite terrible at this game.
- Okay
- But, audience fear not.
Because the left side of the audience,
Kelly is playing for you.
(audience cheers)
- Real sorry!
I'm just really sorry.
- You should hold your
applause till you see her play.
Right side, you get Catherine.
(audience cheers)
- [Catherine] Oh man!
(audience applauds)
- Now here we go.
- Okay, okay.
- Now, Catherine, Kelly
is such a gracious host.
She always allows her guest to go first.
But she's so bad, Kelly, we're
giving you the first choice.
(laughing)
- Oh my God!
- This is so sad.
- And I love you.
- I love you.
- Okay, fine. I'm gonna
take seven. Lucky seven.
- Seven!
- And if it's a hairbrush, I'm gonna.
(laughs)
- I always guess hairbrush.
It always sounds like
a fricking hairbrush.
(audience laughs)
- Now, keep in mind.
- So.
- When you think you know
what this item is.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Buzz in.
- Okay.
- You ready?
- [Kelly] Okay.
(metal clicks and rattles)
(buttons click) (beep)
- Kelly buzzed in first.
- A typewriter? No, no.
(buzzer sounds)
- Oh, oh, oh, oh!
- Let's see if we have white out,
because that is so incorrect.
(laughs) All right, Catherine,
this is now up to you.
You can see if you can
recognize this item.
(metal clicks and rattles)
- Clothes pegs?
- [Kelly] Wait, what?
(buzzer sounds)
- Very close. It was a seatbelt.
Clearly two ladies who, do
not believe in security.
(audience cheers)
- [Kelly] I, I.
- Not so.
- So, Catherine.
- Yeah.
- Now your turn to select a case.
- I am going to do number
eight, my son's birthday.
- [Kelly And Matt] Oh!
- Eight, eight, zero,
zero eight, eight, eight!
- [Kelly] Solid number.
(audience cheers)
- All right, here we go.
- Okay.
- Listen very carefully.
- [Kelly] I do.
(metal scrapes)
(beep)
- Oh!
- Kelly, you buzzed in first again.
- That's the sharpening of a knife.
(audience cheers)
(bell rings)
- [Kelly] Oh my god!
(audience cheers)
- It is history!
- Yes!
- We're getting a word from the judges.
This is the first one Kelly's
done correct this millennium.
(audience cheers)
(hooter sounds)
- [Catherine] Oh!
- I've literally never gotten anything.
I feel like I've just won.
(audience laugh)
Like this is, I don't have
to get any others right.
- Well so much for my son's birthday.
I won't be picking number eight again.
(laughing)
- All right, we have one more,
and I'm just being told this
is now a two point case.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Kelly, your choice with
the game on the line.
Potentially your first
ever victory in this.
- Oh my god, I feel good about this.
Okay. Johnny. Five Alive,
number five. Okay, okay.
- Five Alive.
- Anybody know that movie?
No, okay.
(audience cheers)
Short circuit.
- Now keep in mind, if
Catherine gets this.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- She will be added to
the chicks wall line.
- Yeah, I kind of wanna
see her on the wall.
Yeah. Kinda wanna see her on the wall.
- Okay, here we go.
(metal rattles)
(metal crunches)
(audience laughs)
(beep)
- Again.
- Kelly is buzzing in.
- Like one of those Atticus, like.
Or whatever those things
are called (laughs).
- Abacus.
- Abacus! Abacus!
(buzzer sounds)
- That is incorrect?
- I said Atticus!
- Catherine? You get this
correct and you'll win.
- One more time. One more time.
- Here we go.
(metal rattles)
Do they have elementary school in Wales?
(audience laughs)
(beep)
- Pencil sharpener.
(bell rings)
(audience cheers)
- And she's got it!
- [Kelly] I just heard it, I
just heard it. (hooter sounds)
- Catherine Zeta Jones, you've won.
(audience cheers)
Unbelievable game.
- Thank you.
- I lost when I said Atticus.
(audience cheers)
- Thank you so much.
- Okay.
Everybody wins here, so
our sponsor NetSpend's
All Access mobile account
helps people manage their money
and build a better financial future.
NetSpend's mission is to empower people
to achieve their financial
dreams by providing
access to innovative financial services
and a wealth of kindness.
And today, they're giving
everyone in the audience.
Are you ready for it?
Do you want anything?
Do you want something?
(audience cheers)
- All right. $300 cash!
Also. Also.
Catherine won, which means another thing.
I'm still not good at this game, one.
And two, her photo will go up on
the illustrious chick's wall of champs
who beat Kelly Clarkson.
(triumphant music)
It's a high honor. (laughs)